George.
Yeah,
George coming in.
I'm,
I asked George,
so my work,
they're like,
hey,
can you see what's up with George and this Nate Diaz?
And I'm like,
oh,
ask.
But,
and I'll ask honestly as a friend in it,
and he knows that I'm also employed by somebody who I have a little
conversation,
but,
but I will never ever sacrifice a friendship or like a longterm relationship to
like find something out of it.
Yeah.
I don't care about,
I don't care about Twitter beefs and I don't care about the breaking news and
all that.
Just not interesting.
It's not anything to do with my life.
But I'll go ask George.
So I asked George,
who we are friends,
we talked yesterday and uh,
we will,
he will tell me the truth and then,
and something as simple as all,
you know,
not as fucking bullshit.
Maybe not in exactly those terms,
but he would say.
But when I asked him about it,
he's like,
no,
Bro.
Uh,
I haven't signed nothing.
And I looked at that and like,
oh my God,
that's George tried to be deceptive.
Like George would normally go as be,
man,
that's not happening.
I know I haven't signed anything.
Well,
I know they've offered him,
but that was George,
who's Shitty at being deceptive,
trying to be deceptive like he,
yeah,
so like you said,
they've offered it to,
they've offered it to him and by saying I haven't signed it means he's
considering it.
I think he's considering it,
but I think he's also considering could be number Grumet off and then there's
always the great Irish Leprechaun,
you know?
I mean,
I think those are the two big fights.
The two big fights or could be,
but at one 55 or even one 70 yeah.
GSP wants to winner of Conor McGregor versus could be not Nate Diaz insider
drops bombshell and this is May 19th Saturday.
Oh yeah,
I'm sure he wants that.
But that fight would have to take place first and who the fuck knows when Connor
or it could be,
but fight afterwards,
if it's Connor,
he might be a decade later.
I mean,
who the fuck knows what that guys going to do?
Now when you give a guy like Conor a hundred million dollars,
you know,
I mean this is what happens.
He's throwing dollars at bus windows and losing his fucking mind and yeah,
it's come out of Jamie that UFC inside of a shop,
was it?
Yeah,
it was on his podcast.
I did saw that as I just scrolled down since UFC inside,
I just was Brendan shot those who Brendan Schaub as you fucking idiots.
That some obscure insider.
Yeah,
well I'm sure he does want that,
but if they offer him a fat paycheck and they really should,
if they want.
Look,
the UFC is in a weird position.
They,
they bought the company for $4 billion.
I don't know what it's worth,
but I would guess it's probably not really worth $4 billion.
They have a giant monthly,
not,
it's fucking huge.
The monthly nut that they have to make caused them to fire a hundred employees.
I mean there's a lot going on and there's been some,
you know,
great fights and it's obviously still incredibly popular,
but you want to make those big paper view bucks,
you need the big name stars.
GSP was always a big name star became even bigger when he came back and beat
Bisbing and one by finish.
And so you've got them in a rear naked choke and put them to sleep.
I mean he's still a giant star.
However he hasn't fought in a while.
Vacated at title,
doesn't have the title anymore.
So it's not as big of a deal to the public size when his hit though.
It is,
it is.
People are dumb as shit man.
Yeah.
The funny thing to me is like,
I always feel like,
and,
and I almost feel like a lot of these mechanisms,
title shots,
rankings,
belts,
uh,
you know,
Twitter beefs,
they weren't intended to be there as a short term solution to give people a
talking point until they saw how,
till they got deeply invested in connected.
Right.
And I think that was,
but yet somehow these sort of extra outside distractions became the focus.
Who the fuck cares?
Who's the number eight guy?
And who cares if these guys are mad at each other on Twitter?
And the belt itself has a mechanism for discussion.
What matters is the fight.
Yeah.